time to pull up this story
in a tweet from stephen marsh we've had
on the show he says honestly guys when a
marriage gets like this you sit the kids
down and tell them it's over and you
figure out how to separate with as
little pain and suffering as possible
he links to his article from the
guardian in which he makes a very
important point
he writes
civil wars don't always begin with
gunfire sometimes civil wars begin with
learned arguments in april 1861
confederate forces shot on fort sumter
but at the time even jefferson davis the
confederate president had doubts about
whether the event mattered all that much
it was he claimed quote either the
beginning of a fearful
war or the end of a political contest he
could not say which during the decades
that preceded the assault on fort sumter
complex legal and political figures had
been working their way through the
united states slowly rendering the
country ungovernable and opening the
path to mass violence yo i just got to
say that civil war is coming
from fox news liberals call for
revolution in response to leaked scotus
roe v wade opinion it's not just
liberals there's one guy he's running
for a.g in florida that's my i believe
that's who this guy is it's time for a
revolution these are blue check verified
twitter users taking donations through
act blue advocating for
insurrection
yeah i'll hold my breath and waiting for
the may 2nd commission so i also want to
give one quick shout out to this uh uh
this tweet from madison cawthorne who
said because of donald j trump roe v
wade will be overturned because if you
went 10 years into the past and started
telling people that they would call in a
5150 which for those that aren't
familiar is involuntary commitment to a
hospital for mental issues
donald trump
he's going to be president and then roe
v wade is going to be overturned they're
like okay dude calm down i think you're
losing it that's not gonna happen and
then it did
and here here we are and it's quite
amazing but uh now we have this story
from fox check this out we have other
people maria shriver saying say you want
a revolution well you have one here
right now this person says waking up to
another right for my body being
threatened in 2022 if they want a
revolution they are going to get one
it's not a revolution it's a civil war
the republican position right now is red
states get to choose whether they have
abortions or not and so do blue states
the democrat position is the entire
country should have to allow abortion
one is absolutist one is a compromise
i'll say it again the republicans are
compromising blue states are allowed to
have abortions red states don't and the
democrats are saying no we don't care
you have to have abortions okay that's
not a revolution when you come out and
you say we're gonna force you to have
these laws that's called a civil war
that is not a moral statement about who
is right or wrong it is a fact statement
about what a civil war is so hey civil
war guys no if there is one it's going
to be global that's the problem uh and
the u.s is going to get beat like a
young i'm not going deeper on that and
it'll be corporations will be involved
as well so no not civil war i think
when we're talking about why why people
want the federal government to preserve
abortion rights is because if you're in
a red state or you say you're in a blue
state and then roe v wade gets
overturned and your governor's like
don't worry you can still be here you
set up a family thousands hundreds of
thousands of people move there they live
there they have lives they have
businesses they set up families then a
new governor gets in and it's like yeah
you can't have abortions here anymore
like why would one person get to make
that decision
that's why it's federally instantiated i
believe that why would one person get to
make the decision to allow it that's
another question because they're making
a decision to allow all those unborn
children to die this is funny the people
the left keeps saying men should not be
regulating women's bodies and then
everyone keeps posting a picture of the
supreme court in 1973 which is all men
well and also our you know the um oh my
gosh i'm blanking on her name she was
just uh
dominated by biden
yes that's right she could not answer
the question of what a woman is so what
are they saying when they're talking
about men regulating women's bodies i
just this is the point you know with the
first story about the horse medicine for
abortion it's like dude they they're
saying there's a guy a picture of a guy
in front of the supreme court or
whatever holding a sign saying men
should not be regulating women's bodies
or something like something like if you
uh
okay it was something about like men i
don't know what it said it said if men
could get pregnant then abortion would
be enshrined or whatever and it's like
okay hold on i'm confused now because
y'all are telling me that men could get
pregnant for a long time yeah now you're
telling me that they can't so this is
like an affront i'm just confused at
this point i think this conflict is
going to be really interesting because
it's not
liberal versus conservative
it is
cult
amoral versus
logic i guess
that's one way to put it i'm like oh god
oh no i would just like to ask you
you i'm not sure you uh i'm not sure
which uh you know social circles you're
running and now i'm sure they've changed
since you've detransitioned but i'm
sorry i'm curious what the people around
you have to say about all this and also
the not to put you two on the spot but
the prospect of a civil war in your
opinion
you're 23. tell us he's like do you
think which side will you be on no but i
i am curious about how the people around
you been responding to it that's part of
why i'm so conflicted because i do
i guess um talk to a lot of women who i
do highly respect i think they're
intelligent i think that they are moral
people they're not you know some of
these crazy people that you see in the
most extreme cases and they really
really really care about abortion
and
obviously you know abortion being as
accessible as possible and then i'm just
kind of sitting there thinking like well
hey i don't feel that strongly about it
something about it makes me very
uncomfortable and you know
i get
confused thinking about all of these
different like extreme possibilities of
what could happen because i'm still just
trying to like slow down and think about
okay well is it a human life or not and
i i don't see the argument for why it's
not a human life and then if it is a
human life then how is ending it okay
like that i'm kind of like stuck
there well it sounds like hold on i have
an important question
in in your uh life experience going
through transition and detransition do
you feel that you were lied to by
elements of the left
uh yes absolutely and that's i'm i'm
highly skeptical of that and even when
that uh ralph northam guy
says oh it's between a woman and her
doctor i hear that exact same thing said
about the trans kids it's about the kids
and their doctor and i know that sets
off alarm bells in my head that like
this person's a liar and then so that's
basically my my follow-up question is do
you think that they may be lying to you
about abortion absolutely i i know for a
fact that they are this is this is the
big issue that that i personally face
because uh
you know i mean traditionally liberal my
whole life but now the problem is oh i
love doing this you ready trayvon
martin's story was a lie um jesse
smallette was a lie covington kids was a
lie kyle rittenhouse was a lie russian
gate was a lie ukraine ukraine gate was
a lie ahmed arbory's story was a lie
come on guys what else
the ghost of um ghost of kiev that was a
lie also uh so all of these stories keep
turning out to be false and then i'm
supposed to believe anything these
people say and i'm just like dude i
don't know man
i have i don't i just don't believe you
i don't believe any of them no no no no
hold on all says
i really don't respect or like lindsey
graham or mitch mcconnell or kevin
mccarthy or exactly i don't think those
people are honest either i don't think
they're telling me the truth like when
they share their arguments i'm like
you're a liar too so it's just it's hard
they don't they don't they don't want i
don't think the republicans actually
want um
abortion be banned
because just like the democrats they
need the wedge issue i think for some
number of them they recognize that to
some percentage of the population they
would kind of become politically
irrelevant if abortion was illegal so
some of them probably cynically exploit
the issue but i am curious to to ask you
when you were in the process of
i guess they would call it transitioning
was there anyone in your life who tried
to warn you against it or tried to stop
you from going down that path
um
the only person really would be my
parents but they
i just don't think they really knew how
to handle it i mean how does anyone know
how to handle that yeah um but yeah they
they reacted very emotionally and i
think that that just furthered the
schism between us and just sent me like
it it literally you know ruined our
relationship for like a year we didn't
even talk um so that was pretty much the
only person but everyone else including
at my school it was all like yeah you're
a boy
do you wish that there had been more
people in your life at that time who
would stand up for you and your dignity
and protect you from that definitely
what was that well i think that you can
be that voice for the unborn
because i think you recognize that it is
a life and it does begin at conception
and i think you could do a lot of good
in protecting the innocent in a way that
you weren't protected when you needed
someone so i think everything a really
big portion of this argument that is
left out when it comes to the left
one of the things i heard is what
happens if the um
the placenta breaks early on in the
pregnancy and it's terminal for the baby
and the woman republicans wouldn't allow
an abortion in the circumstance sheamus
yes if that something like that happened
wait could we repeat the question so
someone posted it was like on twitter
and they said
in the instance where a woman is like in
the second trimester and the placenta
breaks it's ruptured and the baby and
the mother will both die unless the baby
is removed they say republicans would
not allow that so again my answer is you
perform whatever surgery is necessary to
save the mother without the intent to
kill the child or without directly
harming the child and if the child dies
as an unfortunate side effect of that
that happens but that's not the same as
an abortion so i think that's an
important semantic component that is
overlooked that when at least you and
matt walsh were describing it you you're
talking about abortion as
specifically and only the intentional
act of killing the baby yeah when you go
in there now i think there could be an
argument to be made that someone could
behave recklessly and kill a child and
be morally culpable for that as well but
again abortion is the direct intentional
murder of an unborn no no involuntary
abortion that's called miscarriage
abortions yes spontaneous abortions
right right it's a medical term that is
sometimes used the spontaneous abortion
is a medical or not that sometimes used
to describe them we're not talking about
we're not talking about the dictionary
we're talking about what is sheamus and
matt walsh's intent in their language
so i can understand
where he's coming from in terms of law
because i don't think it's reasonable if
a woman is like i have a medical issue
with my pregnancy and we're both going
to die it does not make sense to me that
a conservative would be like well then
you have to that no that's why the woman
has the right to carry a weapon a second
amendment to protect herself right well
no the point i'm making is
in talking with seamus and matt as well
as many other pro-life people there's
i've not encountered a circumstance
where a pro-lifer has said the woman and
the baby should both die if they have to
yeah but i'm okay so if we're gonna make
abortion does that include miscarriages
like
like involuntary abortions or are they
just talking about volunteers is it
stroke murder yeah
if you use the cia stroke gun then maybe
but i don't know if it's an induced
stroke if if somebody i i think this is
a silly argument that i've heard quite a
bit and it's just like but what about a
miscarriage and i'm like yeah sometimes
people die we don't you don't go to
prison if you're like a guy has a heart
attack they don't go well time to arrest
somebody yeah it's like what is a
voluntary involuntary is what it comes
down to
and then their people will opt you skate
that obviously and make it seem
involuntary can we have uh
i'd like to i'd like to move over to a
social component i just want to mention
one more thing i think there are
instances where the leftover like i have
read um petitions signed by like
literally hundreds of doctors that have
said there's no such thing as a
medically necessitated abortion there
are instances where surgery might need
to be performed that like poses a risk
to the life of the unborn child but
there's no such thing as an inspiration
but you have to go in and you have to
kill the child and this is important
because what you're saying is
you are not referring to the intentional
act of killing the baby for the sake of
removing it you're saying
in the instance where a mother is has a
medical issue
the intention isn't to kill the baby but
the baby might die because of it yeah
were you always like anti-abortion
growing up my whole life have been
anti-abortion in fact there was a period
of time in my late teens where i really
didn't take my faith seriously and i
think for all intents and purposes i
could probably be described as atheistic
and at no point during that
period in my life that i ever think it
was okay to kill an unborn child i just
couldn't wrap my head around that being
accepted well let me ask you this a
woman is
20 weeks pregnant
and something occurs where the doctor is
like
if we do not terminate this pregnancy
the mother will die
i want to be very careful about this
because as i've said i've i mean i've
read literature from doctors and i've
i've spoken to doctors who have said
that this kind of thing doesn't happen
again there are instances where surgery
could pose a risk to the life of you
instead of talking about we're talking
about like hold on
instead of trying to say it doesn't
happen so i can't answer it let's just
hypothetically
i think i've laid out my principles
right if if there is a surgery that will
save the mother's life but it poses a
risk to the life of a child and that's
the only thing absolute death
like 20 weeks
you will die unless this pregnancy has
ended right now get a second opinion
three doctors tell you that now right
great three doctors all say
yeah the uh the baby is killing you
because of you know this medical issue
yeah if it's the case that the the
mother will die i think you you save her
and you also do everything you can to
save the baby but not intentionally kill
the baby yes yeah absolutely so you
still do everything you can to save the
baby and the mother what if the surgery
is much safer if you kill the baby and
remove it as opposed to a much more
risky procedure where you have you can
try and preserve the baby and maybe the
woman will live uh again i mean we're
getting so that just doesn't exist in my
opinion you destroy the fetus to give
the woman the best chance of survival
but that doesn't mean that scenario
doesn't exist that's like what if you
have to shoot a power cable oh man yeah
it could be mine
yeah i think it was my power cable i
would be more comfortable airing on the
side of do whatever the the most likely
thing for the mother of survival whether
that means if it means that she's got a
ten percent chance less if you go for
the say ah that's so happening you know
it's funny though how many stories have
you heard where a mother who has cancer
for goes chemo to save the life of her
baby it has happened i think it happens
for a while it happens a lot there's a
really famous story that was only i
think a year ago where a woman raised a
bunch of money she said she had cancer
and they said you need to go on chemo
now or you'll die
it'll also kill your baby and she was
like nope baby lives i'll die i always
hate that when doctors are like if you
don't do this then this you know dude
who are what kind of authority do you
think you are yeah you went to med
school good job well i mean you can
choose to trust your doctor
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm now don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you